hey you bozos do yourselves a favor come
out and see the boys live oh yeah stand
up comedy show we play a little ayg with
the crowd fantastic way to introduce new
people to the show so bring the whole
gang out come see us yeah guys get your
best gal friend your best boyfriend the
group chat your homies the bozos anybody
we're gonna be in red bank new jersey uh
in august that show's about to sell out
then we're going to seattle portland
kansas city springfield st louis
nashville indy philadelphia providence
rhode island boston atlanta get those
tickets we'll see you there yeah welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
out they grow it to be classy or they're
just a big old piece of trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here in
auntie's basement she's upstairs she has
turned the living room into a waiting
room she's walking around in a hospital
gown trying to get a free checkup out of
our special guest here my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the ceo of ru garbage he is an
international businessman he is not to
be trifled with in the board room or the
bedroom he is the prince of park avenue
but always the king of the boards baby
give it up for kj kevin james ryan hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube as you know those numbers are
true cooking and then obviously the
greatest website of all time wwe
check it the [ __ ] out we're cooking over
there hey you know and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he works the ones and twos
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen everybody hey what's up dudes
hey t-bones my phones are blowing up my
mom's slipping out of her seat here
dude i'm slipping he walked into that
blazer i was like oh my god
gang we could not be more excited and i
mean not be more excited to have our
incredibly and i mean incredibly special
an honor here with us today this man is
a legendary media personality he is
america's doctor he needs no
introduction but we're going to give him
one anyway because we love him you may
have seen them but not limited to the
simpsons big brother the late show with
craig kilbourne the man show cranky
anchors the sharon osbourne show
strictly sex with dr drew celebrity fit
club the young and the restless craig
ferguson dancing with the stars conan
howard stern tyra banks sex rehab larry
king live jimmy fallon sober house to
tonight's show family guy drunk history
marin wild hogs
i'm bored
we're going to these deep strokes
history tiger valley i did a lot of the
math singer a lot of [ __ ] guys mob wives
pierce morgan teen monster i didn't
remember half of this tom green's live
gut fell asked dr drew the megan kelly
show entertainment tonight wendy
williams dr oz jersey shore family
vacation inside edition fox and friends
gang we ain't done yet listen to this
you've seen him on your mom's house
chelsea lately lopez tonight celebrity
rehab 50 episodes of that throw that in
syndication you come up with a couple of
bucks ladies and gentlemen the bachelor
jimmy kimmel live if i own it which i do
not
the real housewives of beverly hills the
soup real time with bill maher carson
daly 16 and pregnant anderson cooper and
he is also the host of several podcasts
the dr drew podcast the adam and drew
show asked dr drew and of course dr drew
after dark over there you left off home
team with terry bradshaw in 1998.
you left that out i almost forgot he's
one of the stars of sharknado ford the
fourth awakens
and of course he was the host of
loveline from 1984 to 2016. ladies and
gentlemen this man has helped countless
people he has changed countless lives
but the big question about his mind
today is he garbage ladies and gentlemen
the one the only doctor jerome oh thank
you thank you
extraordinary and look at that i've
known him garbage for a long time the
world has let me know that so that's
that's an easy one i was just wondering
about the woman walking around with the
gown on what that was all about the
hospital gown was she excited she was
sort of pushing towards an exam table is
there something i'm supposed to do
it wasn't tied in the back
that's what i'm saying it's like a
little bit weird doc thank you so much
for coming in i appreciate it man so is
it okay for me to say that louis gomez
brought me here
100 shout out to mr louis j gomez it
makes me nervous so i'm nervous being
here but but any friend of his friend of
mine sounds like a set up what's the
backstory of dr joe give us the origins
cali boy yeah
my mom's from philadelphia i'm
philadelphia i thought you guys would
like that yeah left at 18. uh oh my god
there's so much to my story you really
yeah what do you mean
i'm bored by my story get out of here
folks want to hear it she left at 18 uh
to be the fifth wife of a silent film
star
i didn't find this out until i was 55.
all right
was married to him for 10 years had a
stepson and then one day left in a very
don draper-esque fashion and it just
never happened none of us knew it until
the advent of the internet and a friend
of mine found all this history and i was
like huh interesting so then she got
married again to your dad
and my dad was a family practitioner
good guy okay
i was always expected i would do the
same and then when i went to amber's
college i was like this is too hard i'm
not up for this and i drifted around for
a year and a half or so
came back to it i was doing all kinds of
like theater and music and man i've been
my own person man you know kids do and
uh very unhappy like started having
depression and panic attacks
and uh when i went back to the sciences
uh i felt a lot better and suddenly i
could do it i like my brain needed a
mature gotcha yeah he's like like the
young male brain dude watch out for that
it's a dangerous instrument so have some
experience yeah if you're taking eighth
grade classes right now yeah yeah it's
about right you're right on schedule
and i i swear we should put men in the
cage like about 27 yeah with them to
work
uh and then was deeply into it and found
purpose and meaning in medical school i
loved it and
you know went all through fast and um
he became an it went to internal
medicine uh
um residency and then became a chief
resident and taught medicine early in my
residency i started moonlighting at a
psychiatric hospital okay and became
very interested in the medical care of
psychiatric patients and ended up taking
over their medical services
and then about 91 taking over their
addiction services and then taking all
the board certification and that
becoming addiction medicine guy so i had
like three careers in medicine going
simultaneously i was doing hospital
medicine icu medicine which we could do
in those days there was no hospitalist i
did it all
and then at psych setting to medical
care psych patients but then addiction
medicine and then outpatient medicine so
i was i was severe does it all stay
workaholic insane insane all the while
though
in
1983 when i was a fourth year medical
student in 84
started sort of fumbled into this radio
show that was a block away from my
apartment right on this radio station
that had become a
force in rock rock which was not nothing
like literally over six months became
this poof became this mega hit
and because i lived a block away people
i knew were starting to go over there
and socialize with people and this one
guy called me and he goes hey they have
this show in the middle of the night
they need to they have to make it a
community service show they want you to
do a segment called ask a surgeon
they'll be really funny you use big
words to be hysterical
what are you talking about but i was
convinced to go meet with the guys and
went in
and was blown away by the kinds of
questions are being asked to these guys
in the middle of the night and by the at
that same time
one anthony fauci who i admired very
much at that time was telling us young
physicians we had to go educate about
hiv and aids we he was banging back then
oh yeah yeah he was a big deal yeah what
do you think that was good
was his big success we had just started
calling the disease aids we didn't have
a causative agent yet we had htlv3
but there was a lot of pressure to go
educate go educate graduate i thought
okay yeah why not no one is and the one
of the first thing that struck me about
uh when i went up there is no nobody was
talking to young people about hiv and
well about what you're just starting to
call hey sure and i was like jesus
christ i'm i'm 24 years old i know what
19 year olds are up to and in the eyes
of
the world at that time
adolescence we just had the sexual
revolution in the 70s but adolescents
weren't having sex why would they have
sex like give me a [ __ ] break so i
kid i knew what was going on i knew
somebody didn't just tell me i know your
kids are doing up there and everything
was shrouded in mystery you to get a
condom you had to go up to the
pharmacist and ask them to bring it
behind the counter
sexually transmitted i remember that
you're not old enough for that
i remember getting it from behind the
camera really i never used them i want
to be on record but to be fair
he was nine when he got his first round
and the guy was very nice
not nice gentle different
and and uh shout out to the mudslides
and applebee's
wow
so glad i'm here
and uh where was i so i was start we
started talking about safe sex before
the term had been invented yet that's
wild and you know sexually transmitted
illnesses were shrouded in mysterious
latin venereal diseases monalia you know
it's all this weird language that this
is [ __ ] this is really easy stuff
bacteria causes it's called gonorrhoea
nice syrian no big deal take some
penicillin you'll be fine and just
teaching people about it and
it was considered outrageous to talk to
young people about sexually transmitted
illnesses and reproductive health and
then at the same time as we went along
we were hearing about trauma trauma
trauma trauma drugs and alcohol drugs
alcohol figured prominently and all that
and as that was starting my my expertise
in that was developing so i focused a
lot on that and then you know and then
you know somebody
said let's do a tv show or someone said
let's do it five nights a week and i was
like whoa [ __ ] how are we gonna do that
was only one night a week forever for
ten years and i'm like oh my god i
worked on nine o'clock at night how are
we going to do that
and did that and then it was like hey
let's syndicate this like okay what's
that mean and then then some producers
can't show up let's make a television
show like all right how do you do that
sounds interesting so just doors would
open and i would just go all right let's
try that see how it works it sounds like
interesting let's see if i can make
something good out of it and that was
mtv that we were on there for five five
seasons right
and uh and then i think i just did radio
for a long time and then somebody showed
up and wanted to do celebrity rehab and
i was like well you can't do that
there's no way no that's when i fell in
love with that
that show was a [ __ ] game-changer oh
that was a hard thing to to do i could
imagine and so i was running a program
then we had a big program and uh
these these excellent producers showed
up going to do this i said
you can't do it at a hospital you cannot
do that you can't bring cameras to a
hospital no way and they said oh let me
talk to you
let me just talk to them so they talked
to my hospital and they literally
laughed them out of the building yeah
and so we i still went around to pitch
it i'm like all right i'll pitch it with
you guys and then vh1 showed interest
and i kind of went into hiding
and um because i thought no no way we
can't do this you know
what we're going to do and bob forrest
who was my clinical director at the time
came into my office and he goes you know
he didn't know he had no idea people
were talking to me about this he goes
you know i'm so sick and tired we
treated a number of celebrities not
exclusively celebrities in fact even not
even predominantly celebrities right but
a number of them and you never knew but
you never find out about it we were
extremely circumspect about our
treatment
and he goes i'm so tired of these
television reporters reporting what our
patients are doing as being on some sort
of a spa vacation or an excuse for their
behavior these people are sick they work
hard we got to do a tv show we show we
show that i was like i was stunned i'm
all right well it's funny and i told him
what was happening he goes he just did
this he goes he goes
yes we got to do it he's jumped up and
he walked out of my room there you go
and that was it and i thought all right
i guess we'll move forward still a
million hurdles to climb and i couldn't
see how they were going to do it and
then i thought of the passing recovery
center was a place where i'd i'd done
some coverage for the psychiatrist up
there
and i thought
i bet i could take break might take my
team and just put them into one of their
units and just take it over and use
their policies and procedures and run a
program that's what we did man was it
look at this and so the so the cameras
ran and we just ran the program the way
we always do so that's awesome oh we had
other problems too yeah there was one
hurdle left another then we found out
they weren't licensed for me to do group
in the facility so we had to build a
double wide trailer out in the parking
lot that's not on the property that's
not on the private a separate address
you're blinded your real gray area well
you're blind you see the patients leave
the unit and then walk into the
group room but they actually had to walk
across a parking lot international
orders yeah
go down to tijuana take it back for me a
little bit so your your mom married your
dad yeah so you didn't know anything
about the silent film starting like that
yeah how many brothers and sisters did
you have a sister she's not six years
younger than me and she's a mom now out
and you know doing real well okay and
dude you got you said you so your dad
was a doctor was your mom a stay-at-home
mom did she work no she had a crazy life
so when she was absconded by the film
star
it'd be the fifth wife she was barely
18. did she meet him
i don't know what else i don't know i
don't know
did your dad know about this we don't
know he was already gone by the time i
and your mom was going by your mom no
she was still around it and my sister
freaked out and i was like
she's she's kept it this far that's how
they did it back then i know that's not
i know it's don draper man and she wants
to take it to the grave i want to let
her do that yeah you know what i mean
it's like okay then i'm going to talk
all about as soon as she's gone
then i'm going on are you garbage and
airing out her dirty laundry save it for
the book but because it's i have no ill
feeling about it for her that she had to
feel so guilty it's also it's like
that's a lifetime yeah what are you
gonna do well so i i ended up talking to
her stepson who was a retired dentist in
stockton it was interesting yeah
but you know with no hard feelings and
whatever but people live the life they
live of course and how was your how was
your update
he makes me feel good about my bad
decisions
i swear i mean
one day they'll talk [ __ ] about you but
they'll forgive you yeah there'll be
times like you go through yeah you have
like a std scare or something and he
would be like oh it's herpes who cares
i'm like yeah who cares i'll get back
out i'm talking to a wizard i love it
it's a rash um traditional upgrading
trust me dr drew i've said it a thousand
times to myself
tell my wife that way well even more no
big deal because that means you're not
gonna cheat
also
[Laughter]
traditional upbringing yeah single
family home yep nice nice that was a
doctor probably
yeah good but he's very very uh
traumatized by the depression and he
rained all that down on me
okay yeah yeah say he was a saver oh not
more than that
like when i was uh two three years old
he would he started in on me mike he did
it tried it to my kids too and they
laughed at him but i was traumatized by
it because your dad grandpa does it it's
one thing your dad does it it's a whole
different matter and uh he would you
know he'd see like i need a new pair of
shoes or something goes oh you need to
do shoes okay well two or three jesus
like young maybe four all right and he
first regaled me with you know my day we
had to have holes in the shoe walking
chicago
and i was like okay okay and then it's
like go ahead get your shoes but
after you do that tomorrow
i i won't be here i'll be in the poor
house and you come visit me in the poor
house it has a window in the front so
you can wave to me through the window
and i had this whole [ __ ] place in my
head that was right i was going to send
my dad to the poor house if i bought
clothing so to this day i cannot buy
clothing i can't do it my wife has to do
it yeah i can't i can't i don't [ __ ] yet
playing mind games with that toddler
yeah so he was more than saving he was
like obsessed yeah with uh not spending
anything on anything would he spend it
on did he have nice cars or any
vacations yeah it was actually okay
later later you know so my sister got
none of it even just six years later she
seemed to have gotten none of it and so
it must have been an early thing for him
that he came once he got some room to
breathe that
wasn't so bad but he always worked maybe
on that stuff always he's all right i
mean i i it made me a good you know
savior sure savior any pets growing up
uh dogs cats dogs
wow i had parakeets for a while are they
loose in the house or were they no no no
no in cages okay i did that i had a
weird feeling about birds weird no one's
ever talked to me about this
like a weird show
weird weird garbage-like feeling
so um
i can't let the media know i had
parakeets
no i just i don't know what it was i
remember one died when i was real little
like maybe a year and a half old
we moved out of the house we were in
alhambra alejandra at the time
and uh so i know all the memories i have
of that house was under the age of two
because we moved when i turned two
and there was something the bird died
and it really affected me for some
reason and so i always had this funny
feeling about the birds yeah and to this
day i look at birds and i'm just
fascinated by them like of course the
way that i mean these are dinosaurs
these guys scare the [ __ ] out of me they
should yeah
they thank you they're eight thousand
feet in the air and they see you dudes
keep it moving do you have any pets now
yeah we have uh two dogs and my
daughter's cat has now just moved in uh
but we have our dog is an australian
shepherd yeah okay we sort of really
love the the shepherds uh so [ __ ]
smart play sports anything like that
when you were yeah i was like it was a
source of figured out good frame of
course figured large into my life so i
was uh
you know started freshman football i was
shitty
and was in the process of quitting
and i remember the coach came up to me
and went right in my mask and went uh
stick with this you're gonna get this
and it affected me profoundly and i
stuck with it ended up being the captain
of the football team my senior year all
city all whatever what yeah i mean i was
i could hit all city or whatever i don't
remember all see i have no i don't know
of course
it was you know as adam would say it was
a small school sure he's still got a
call
captain of the squad little lord font
leroy school for albino hemophilia
good school back then and it still is
today folks
but it meant a lot to me shout out to
the course it meant a lot to me and i'm
glad it was small so i could actually
have that experience you know of
overcoming all that and then you know
being a performer at that level of
course what was the school mascot
panther the panther dead pretty classy
i don't know the name of this what was
the name of the street that you grew up
on madeline drive
sounds classy you guys have a pool no it
was a it was
you really want to hear all this [ __ ]
what do you mean this is
i've never had such a big figure meeting
me like this show's stupid
and you're not wrong yeah i feel stupid
what do you mean because i feel like i
don't who wants to hear this everybody
we found out everybody wants to hear
that if you think it's stupid now
give it a half an hour so
so i grew up in i'm ready for that
that's more of what i'm used to guys
i'm not talking about myself now the
word from our sponsor better help yes
gang if you got something that's kind of
standing in the way of your happiness do
yourself a favor and get on better help
if something was broke in the house the
dishwasher the washing machine the
shower wasn't running you would call
somebody and you would get it fixed it's
called professional who knows what
they're talking about that's right and
the most important relationship you have
with anybody on this planet is a
relationship with yourself so do
yourself a favor and reach out to better
help i promise you they can help yes uh
guys uh talk therapy has helped me a lot
in the past it's fan it's a fantastic
tool it's easy peasy
uh and
if it it it just gives you a little
clearer a little uh you know makes you
see things a little clearer make sure
things see things a little different and
get you back on the right path better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat therapy
sessions so you don't have to see
anybody if you don't want to but you can
if you want whatever is best for you
give you a little bit of anonymity there
you go that was my word of the day it's
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours which is huge if
you've ever tried to find a therapist it
is a daunting process you call them
they're seeing a patient they call you
back you miss the call it takes it can
take weeks or months and you might not
have specialists in your town that can
help you with better help you got access
to all that yes uh so right now our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
garbage do it now back to that show back
to the show all right so alhambra until
h2 and then this other house which is
this strange
it was a strange um mid-century modern
lots of glass
and it was built on the grounds on a
little tiny piece of the grounds of the
bush gardens estate if you look at the
bush gardens in pasadena it was this
famous garden of the bush the bush
family right the beer family that they
built as an attraction people would come
and visit it and we actually had a pond
in our backyard that my mother filled in
she was very paranoid with dirt because
she was convinced i was going to drown
in it or i had her who knows what the
hell
and um
it was just this very unusual property
that i always thought was kind of
magical on the outside but on the inside
i never felt safe it was always too much
glass and cause it just didn't feel good
and then uh
i don't know and then i i couldn't wait
to get away 17 i went to college and i
was out and never came back never good
student i assume yeah i became a much
much i was a very good student i became
a really good student later you remember
what you got on the sats did you guys i
remember the math was like a 7 20. so
that means that the that's good it was
good it means like the english must not
have been so good i don't remember that
you got a 7 40 time i got in amherst
college that's all i wanted to go that's
great so and they and they kicked my ass
oh my god did they kick my face
but that was the most important thing i
ever did huh yeah it's pretty good slip
and slide growing up yep stuff inside
really for sure
on the grass of that filled in pond
there you go next to the busch gardens
in the busch gardens in the bush gardens
what was the family vacations like
growing up as a kid
so they had a condominium down at laguna
beach that i actually
me and my sister are acquired now
and uh now this is laguna beach
california i know but is it it's not
quite at that time it's not what it is
now no it's like tribeca in the
yeah then then it was
mostly hari krishna and hippies okay uh
and then it became mostly gay and then
it became wealthier all of a sudden it
was weird to see that happen but uh it
it was i i love the beach everything in
the water right to get in the water 10
o'clock in the morning i'd get out five
in the afternoon it was very important
to me i just loved that i ended up
guarding lifeguarding that beach very
interesting you were a lifeguard
what age were we talking 1920 21. damn
man that's like baywatch that's prime
[ __ ] lifeguard yeah i'm looking tight
out it was a it was an intense speech i
could not do it now you ever have to
save anybody every day you ever see any
sharks uh yeah but they were california
blues they didn't hurt anybody but uh
it sounds cool sounds like some
mid-grain but yeah somebody out every
day i mean it was it's a rough beach
yeah and i i could i would i had such
good water in things i could see when
the person stepped foot on the sand
you're like this guy's fine
this fat piece of [ __ ] don't go in
hey tubby go get a knife there was no
stopping people there's no style they're
gorgeous i'll get them afterwards uh
what was the first concert you went to
uh
i believe it was elton john yellerbook
road damn that's that's [ __ ] cool
i'd lose my first date too
really yeah yeah all right i've just
started driving that's a big ticket what
kind of car were you driving back in the
day i'd have a car oh my dad had a 57
thunderbird i used to drive that holy
[ __ ] yeah but that was a you understand
those pieces of [ __ ]
it was 1973 or whatever i would look
like an [ __ ] driving that thing
you've got to understand something like
why did that did you keep that card such
a piece of [ __ ] yeah you didn't want to
end up in the poor house you know what i
mean exactly i picked you like sonny in
a bronx table
i pictured it was 1955 but it was 78 or
whatever
what was the name of the grocery store
that your mom went to when you were a
kid do you remember
well the one laguna was alpha beta i
remember that okay uh
there was a market basket in south
pasadena remember that marketplace
that's also in boston yeah right and i
think there was a ralph this is where we
went okay shout out to where do you shop
now ralph's
maybe that's why i think that it's the
same story do you do the shopping now or
do you do like the online i do the yeah
i do the instacart yeah my wife does the
shopping shopping okay
would you say you have a favorite flavor
of gatorade
i hate gatorade okay this guy's not
drinking gatorade no i drink i drink we
gotta ask the question so listen man i i
drink uh
[ __ ] i drink these hydration products
like liquid iv and stuff like that yeah
so do we just use spots at it this
morning hydrolyzed
now i like the taste of them better yeah
and watermelon
you're gonna hear about me doing
something where my hydration
i can't talk about it yet i'm really
forbidden for talking about it okay but
i will i will happily talk to you guys
about it when the time comes i'm not
sure if it's gonna be the fall or the
winter but hydration figures big into
what i was doing that's all i'll tell
you power it's got a cease and desist
okay
vacations do you fold your pizza
i have i don't like to what's your
favorite kind of pizza oh i like tony's
down here okay yeah oh new york pizza
come on it's just come on it's the best
that's best
isn't it anthony's or tony's in times
square over there on seven seventh
avenue you go up towards 59th is one i
just because i used to i used to stay at
hotels on central park south right so
i'd always just go around the corner and
i'd love that that's class central park
south 59th street right at the park
because i worked at cnn for ten years
and so i just they put me up down the
street all right very nice very unique
you ever state that jw marriott right
there the essex house essex yeah it's
nice it's got a little bit of cash
showing up no no i didn't pay for it
don't
i have paid for it but routinely i
didn't know uh have you ever been on a
cruise oh we love cruises really yeah
we're going to portugal next fall yeah i
know my wife and i
we went to baltic cruise it was
fantastic
i don't like packing and unpacking and
trains and places and i like seeing lots
of different places and so we just do it
we'll just get on something we would we
do like one of the tour that's like we
were in greece last summer and we spent
a week on santorini and then we got on a
boat for a while and saw more stuff hmm
he just said
he just convinced me that you are going
to give [ __ ] to people who ride cruises
of course
i'll convince you otherwise yeah i mean
i'm about to book a cruise we have fun
at these things we really we've met
great people we still keep in touch with
lots of them this has got to be a higher
class
it's small crews like windstar that kind
of thing ah right now
that's not
no no all right
yeah i can't see you on i can't see you
on the [ __ ] you're not on the water
slide
in the waterslide no no no no no i but
i've done uh is it norwegian i think a
big boat baltic it was still very good
okay all right you ever uh you ever
named a star after anybody
uh uh have i yeah uh a star has been
named after me and adam
or an asteroid or something yeah an
asteroid yeah right
he's got kippy do you own a tux yeah a
couple
i have to how many suits do you think
you and you wear suits every day no i
don't i have i wear sport coats like
this stuff this thing okay i've got
well
i do a lot of tv and sometimes they give
you sure of course
you have like sports eight suits do you
have a walk-in closet without with all
your stuff and get your shoes laid out
well
i'm not the most organized shoe guy so
there's a lot of shoes on the floor yes
but my clothing is pretty well laid out
okay hung up any magicians in the family
my brother-in-law whoa
this is why we play the game
who wants to hear this
is he promising is it a career or it's
like uh he's a he's actually an
anthropologist he was a college
professor okay but he always wasn't even
his trash is close
magician he's a member of the magic
castle in los angeles so we would go to
the magic castle with him okay what kind
of magic does he is like slightly like
close-up magic or yeah general stuff
generally sort of like cards and ropes
and things like that i remember knots on
ropes
is there a sandwich named after you
anywhere the dr drew that i know is your
head shot in any restaurant or pizza
place yeah
have you ever car wash car a car wash
you're built for the show dr drew you
got your head shot in a [ __ ] car wash
shout out to the pasty car wash in del
mar shout out to him
he just got another another month of
free cleaning i wish
tony keep the super washers coming
this is good yeah what kind of stuff i
told you i was garbage
you're but it's a very my wife you go on
cruises but they're boutique yeah my
wife is more white trash than i am
celebrates your white trash where's your
wife from newport beach but newport
beach sort of inland and before it was
newport beach
back when laguna was hippies yeah that
was her newport beach her dad owned
hardware stores okay all right do you
guys ever eat dinner on the couch
watching tv all the time really is there
tv trays no you just hold it yeah we
kind of have a pad there like like a
ottoman with short on that but the dogs
will eat it so we have to put in our
drinks of course
we'll get it that was good uh what kind
of soap do you use in the shower
irish spring you do what's wrong with
that no it's i also i'm a spring man
myself
we we have a condo here in new york so
we're here
so hold on
you can't use irish freak
wait a minute you're an esteemed man of
medicine wait a minute it gets worse so
we have a condo here stolen we're here
in the city all the time okay and i
couldn't find irish spring so i have to
get dial so i've got some or yellow dial
in my shower right now so you keep a
condo and i don't like it yes that's
very classy classy very nice and then
you have the house out yeah squatters
writes in it but
it's not fully out it's the size of it's
smaller
studio trust me yeah
there we go oh man you own a police
scanner no ever been in a feud with a
neighbor
oh i'm sure but mostly my wife does
those okay
that's what you want handle that was the
dirty word we had one yeah we had a
before we were downtown we had a place
in the upper west side yes we had a
major feud i can't even talk about it
shrub injury shrub stuff trees are a big
one yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm trying to think we
no oh yeah we had a fence fence problem
oh really yeah where like the property
line it was oh yeah he came out and
mapped it out himself and wouldn't yeah
they're always wrong they're always
wrong yeah it's like we're done with
that you got a pool in the backyard now
your house happens in in california hot
tub too yes
are they connected like like overflow is
there a waterfall yes nice is there an
outdoor like cooking area with the grill
yes
their house is passing we [ __ ] love
that place yeah i love it too but it
sounds right
i'm so happy with that in fact it's a
little too nice all my kids have bounced
back home and
during covet and have been enjoying it
too yeah there you go but i'm glad we
have it anyway salt water pool yes it is
well i don't but the salt's not working
so i think we have we're chlorinated now
again i think yeah it's weird
i don't ask questions can you walk in or
is it steps do you have like the walk-in
beaches oh no yeah it's steps there's a
ledge yeah is there a slide no
diving board no
you can't do that anymore in california
or at least not southern california it's
illegal yeah
any neck injuries do you floss every day
yeah every day twice a day you do every
day twice a day got a good set of
treatments i have a great dentist that
got i was not like that he just inspired
me somehow now i do and some [ __ ]
wood picks for my gums really yeah i do
the uh yeah the slides the whatever they
are so you go to the dentist regularly
regularly got to go next week you guys
own a swiffer oh hell yeah how about a
roomba
uh we have
no they've never really worked have you
had pink eye in the last 365 days i've
got a dry eye syndrome so i frequently
have non-infectious stuff like that but
uh no infectious pink eye do you ever
meet willie nelson or meryl haggart
for sure willie nelson really with his
guitar and his
[ __ ]
his trailer if you walk into you'll get
higher [ __ ] your po calls but i think
merle haggard's son was running around
for a while right isn't it yeah i think
i met his son okay and didn't he have i
think he died maybe or something i don't
know anybody get in the car yeah get on
that t-bunch anyway dude i'm not bro
hiring himself though
hmm um do you take your shoes off on a
plane
no rarely sometimes yeah it's a long
long long long level yeah okay are your
shoes off in the house
here in new york but not at home yeah
new york's different yeah yeah that's
good flying first class i would assume
right never first class usually i try to
get business if i can but i i don't care
anymore i just don't care i just said
the price as much as you're traveling
the prices are dead crazy
i think next week i'm doing coach i
think why yeah i don't care i'm busy i
do i have to do it
if i can get it i'll do it and if i have
to sleep then i insist if if i need to
sleep on the flight like i've got to get
up and do something in the morning yes
yes then but otherwise i'm giving [ __ ]
well
plus i've got a i've got to do medical
education consuming cme it's called and
so i'd have to do these tests all the
time and i just do them on the plane
whenever i'm flying so damn i usually
watch a movie i sometimes do a
masturbating bathroom
just saying
will you blow under no phone
i buy the wi-fi
i have a delta wi-fi subscription for
the month it's 49.99 not going in there
cold turkey what do you think just
checking
um will you bring food on an airplane
yes
what do you bring uh prosciutto cheese
i
nut butter i'm on a low carb thing yeah
he's keeps it guys chisel i saw you with
sirius xm probably three it was before
the pandemic oh i think so
and i was there a lot i i saw you and i
was like i think i texted him i'm like
dr drew is even better looking in person
kick the [ __ ] out of it
you have a go-to karaoke song uh
god damn it i was just thinking about
this this morning that the the stuff so
you know i when i was drifting around
there during those years in college
there was a minute where i was going to
be an opera singer and i ended up
continuing that training all the way
through medical school so i sing and i
get sold as a i'll sing national anthems
at ball games no
nhl game's the best holy [ __ ] on the ice
it's like singing in the shower wait and
they say now to sing the national anthem
doctor [ __ ] andrew the king so far
but anybody else wants me to do it i
love doing that holy [ __ ] yeah and i've
lost mary did the mass singer and oh
yeah that's right uh
and uh
any event so so
that my era was a long time ago of of
the kinds of stuff i liked singing it
was really because they're classical
musicals and so if ever i would leave
you and come fly with me and stuff like
that is what i do when i say classic i
mean karaoke is trashy intrinsically but
then you're doing come fly with me
that's a [ __ ] pretty good
man he's pretty good all right whatever
any beekeepers in the family no
thankfully when was the last time you
were at an applebee's tji fridays or
olive garden
or anything similar yeah i have not
frequented that i i remember in being in
birmingham alabama and being at
applebee's and it was uh michelin star
down there yeah it was they really
enjoyed it oh no the tgif was tj
friday's and uh that was about my last
time
how about folk of the ciao benihana
outback or an ihop
uh i helped my sons love they they
played football too and they would do
that before so yes but that was back
when they were in high school all right
29 i have triplets i have 29 year old
children oh [ __ ] really yeah yeah and uh
they were no a girl and they were good
football players too they were better
than me i had them i started with
certain junior all-american with them
when they were little and they really
learned how to the basics and so they
were good football players um
the pogo to whatever
yeah i think i did something like that
recently yeah i think i think that's
where they give you like the car you say
keep it coming
or any brazilian second stream
[Applause]
have you ever been in an event where
someone asked if there was a doctor in
the house many times on a planet
and the term yes on a plane the term
doctor has become been so [ __ ]
bastardized
that i no longer say i'm a doctor i
either say i'm a physician
or i'm the kind of doctor that when they
say is there a doctor on the plane i
stand up
because people don't even understand
what the term it doesn't mean medical
doctor anymore it could mean
musicologist right and so that's what i
say
and i have just like a couple nights ago
i was uh on the middle of the street and
somebody fell down i you know did my job
you went over and helped him yeah yeah
can you imagine coming too and dr drew's
over time i'm gonna kiss him like wendy
peppercorns
it happened on a plane once so i was uh
i was on a plane and you got your
prosciutto in your hand
can you hold this please i think it was
like deep in the shawshank here let's go
i kind of like southwest i like the
whole vibe of it so i think it was a
southwest flight you wanted yeah you're
gonna tell me your spirit kind of got no
idea i bet you really let your hair down
on these cruises too by the way
the hawaiian shirts come out like a
jimmy buffett cruise or something
when i'm on a
cruise um but i was i i could i heard
the guy talk on the phone behind me and
i could tell he was a intensivist or
oncologist or something and uh and they
go doctor on the plane so he and i stood
up we went over this woman's sort of
losing consciousness
and she was we you know we took care of
her and whatever and we stabilize her
and she looks and she goes i'm a huge
fan of yours when you take a selfie
that's why you check my vitals and take
a little selfie with her just after we
hit the ground before the paramedics
came on and took her she got the oxygen
mask on yeah yeah okay
is there much you can do in the moment
on the plane because i'm like it's not
like he got like your little bag within
you like well they're kind of limited
but you you were also doing assessment
and how bad it is trying to see what's
wrong if you had a tracheotomy somebody
on the plane could you like they'd do it
i always fear that i would be called
upon to do that i could but i have very
little experience doing that and i would
be bad at it don't you have to have a
certain kind of pen on you to do that
yeah you have to hold certain kind of a
lot of stuff yeah to do it properly you
have to really be able to get it it's
not as easy as you think
you've got to hit the exact right spot
man macgyver makes it look pretty easy i
don't know and i don't know you know i
um i i really actually worry about it
because i'm not sure that a
you know these pens are going to be
enough for somebody to get air through
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think that's going to not my mom blanc
airway management yeah at least i had up
at a football game i was my kids are
playing and uh i noticed across the
field one of their friends was doing one
of these back and forth kind of things
like he didn't know what to do and i
thought oh [ __ ] there's a problem so i
just started running and i went over
there superhero and there's uh one of
their peers a kid i liked a lot seizing
and i thought oh [ __ ] it's either neck
or bleed into his head and i had to
breathe for him and i had to do all the
stuff and his dad's standing over me
going he's gonna be okay right he's and
i'm thinking oh my god the best this is
gonna be is like wheelchair no language
and um
next next guy to show up about 15
minutes later was the head of the er
down the street he called for a
neurosurgeon we got it we got him right
into the operating room and that kid
went to you know was in chemistry
classic and you're you're you're going
with them from the field to the house
your doctor
he was kind of it wasn't really seizing
it was just sort of like this when your
brain is [ __ ] up like that you can't
breathe yeah it's a wire you're sort of
shaking unless oh you're having a
seizure have you ever gone in the
chopper with anybody and landed on the
on the roof
uh i've been in a chopper
has something to do with upcoming tv
that i'm doing okay all right all right
we can cut that out yeah do you have
cash app
uh like pay paypal yeah no cash app is a
ca as an actual it's like a discount no
no no okay
how much cash do you have on you now
let's see
and what kind of wallet do you have is
that a two me no my son gave me this i
think it's a uh
this is that a metro card yeah you take
the [ __ ] subway
i think i got here
get them out of here i do this thing now
with the metro i do the phone
card
yeah i know yeah
i feel like a [ __ ] rockefeller
rolling in there what am i doing so i
have 50 or 50 a 20
95 95 b not bad that's really i think
it's been the same for about seven
months
don't throw the kids around
but yeah i love running the trains here
i love it it's so convenient it's so
great i just i love this city i love
this city man he's a good there's
nothing like that in l.a you can't
stroke a car everywhere jesus christ and
i guess by the way the roads don't work
there the freeway is all jammed up
they're all jammed up here and homeless
like
zombies walking between you this is we
were just in l.a and you know there's a
lot of crossover between us being in new
york and the comics that come from l.a
and everything everybody in l.a thinks
new york is like a hellscape and
everybody in new york thinks la's a
hellscape
you are right yeah well new york was a
hellscape during covet i didn't like it
it's not great anymore i don't know i
just talked to a couple of new york
police officers just at on the subway
stand just someone was a fan and wanted
a picture and of course they were you're
[ __ ] dr drew and and i said i said
you know i said look you know i because
i'm sure i haven't been here four months
that's unusual for me i'm usually here
all the time because i found it
depressing to come here it was yeah it
was four months ago it was shitty and
now it feels more like new york a little
bit yeah it is i think it's the tourists
and stuff bit of a heartbeat coming back
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure and i i talked and i
said you know i feel good as i think
it's going okay she goes no they're
horrible and i go and i go well it's
because you guys are dealing with it
that's why it feels better for us so
thank you it's very true so
hmm yeah so we have so much white dress
stuff i can't even
yeah we have i but i'll notice it comes
in through my wife's side and so we got
it it's the magic castle
what's one thing that she does where
you're like we're do that you might draw
a line of like we're not doing that or
you know you guys that's kind of is
there anything like that i wish you
would
spending all the loot over here
uh dad [ __ ] turned over in his grave
i had a two for one for that
i insist she buy clothing on sale though
i can't do it any other way
so real real
have you guys had a whole turkey on any
other day but thanksgiving you ever do a
whole turkey she does duck
i know i'm sorry
that's even close here
she's chock check and she really values
my wife's jacket same thing big on the
goose
good looking people healthy people yeah
you ain't lying yeah it's true uh and
and uh yeah she'll do goose just it's
usually in preparation for a holiday but
she'll just do it sometimes too do you
guys do surprise parties in your family
no no no surprise parties
very nice yeah have you had a lunchable
or a bagel bite in the last 365 days
no way he's eating prosciutto on a plane
well but i but i'll go to lunchables if
i'm stuck
yeah but i don't think i've found so
many other ways to get meat and cheese
that i don't think i've done lunchables
in a long way
but i'm not beneath it okay you cut it
cheese man you like cottage cheese yeah
do you have any bumper stickers on your
car no what kind of kind of what are you
wearing
but after i had covet i backed into a uh
this two years ago i backed into a poll
so it's got a huge dent in the
background i refused to fix it wait why
because it was such an asshole-ish move
i want to remind myself every day what
garbage i am you're driving around in a
what's the misses riding around then uh
an audi nice yeah okay there we go yeah
thanks the audi is a classy is the
classy understated look very classy yeah
but i think we're really thinking about
getting rid of all that and doing some
kind of electric car or something okay
it's just getting so ridiculous
california it's [ __ ] five six dollars
a gallon yeah it's getting crazy they
said we just crossed the front the
threshold of uh that five percent of the
cars being bought are electric and they
say that yeah but i i don't see where
it's gonna the the expense and the and
the the impact on the environment it's
gonna be about the same it's gonna be
the same it just drives you crazy to
fill up for 150 every time you go to the
gas station sure you guys own a drone
do not no drones no drones that's
interesting i would think my sons would
get into that but they do not have you
ever left a bad yelp review
my wife has okay i have not nice do you
know the situation
i can't but i know she has i'm sure she
has i've seen her talking about stuff
let's say you get invited to a wedding
all right one of the kids uh one of
their friends are getting married you go
to the wedding
what are you putting in the envelope
what are you dropping on the web
cash-wise yeah
i we don't tend to bring cash we tend to
buy stuff okay and uh
i
because i have a problem
i have my wife do it i just closed my
it's the classy answer i know that's
classy
this is just pathology it's
psychopathology it's really this guy
calls it lexie season let's say you and
corolla go out to dinner yeah do it with
with you know we do it all the time okay
we go by ourselves a lot who's picking
up the check how do you guys uh we
usually split split it yeah but he we
we've gone back and forth a few times
too but
he's
he's all about equity okay really yeah
we go we get a steak and a martini and a
salad very often really yeah that's what
you like martinis that's what he likes
i don't really like it that much but
i'll stay with him what are you drinking
i like glass of wine glass of wine red
wine
i'm on this no carb thing right so i
flipped over to chablis strangely we
were in france a year ago and i found
chabot what that is
it's hard to find that makes it even
classier dr drew
i can't understand why it's not around
but now you're not ordering a coors
light
too much cars so many cars i know i'm
trying to get off the booze myself i'm
really i'm obsessed about the carb thing
and i've been drifting for a while i was
really i was very religious about three
years i don't know he hasn't done carbs
in two years so you know i'm not sure if
it's working
i put on 12 pounds
let's get into the big hitters here all
right good are you peeing in the shower
oh sure really sure that's a doctor's
saying remember i have prostate cancer
right and so i had my prostate removed
okay so it's a little harder to control
things like that when the heat comes on
right
there's
do you brush your teeth in the shower no
but i shave in the shower
and you know i i was doing some sort of
it does have great skin do you have a
mirror in there no i do it all without
mirror but but i but it's a problem in
in southern california because we have
to save water we have a big drought and
so it's like [ __ ] i turned the water off
this whole thing but but i i for years i
was bleeding every day damn man you're
shaving blind no no no
not shower and there's finally this guy
goes well that's not right i got a guy a
journalist that specialized in shaving i
just i don't know why i ran into this
guy and i was talking like i got bleed
every day what do i do because that
shouldn't happen and he goes have you
tried this i tried everything and
finally goes do it in the shower and
that took care of it wow just using a
regular like bic razor i do i have a
whole procedure i don't want to shave i
do a brush i have a couple razors i use
you know brushes classic i go at it kind
of it's easy and then really get at it
wow damn yeah it's a whole
ridiculousness shaving ocd i have ocd in
case you didn't know join the club now
you're in good you have anxiety disorder
a generous anxiety disorder that sort of
drifts towards ocd
what's the sleeping situation king-sized
bed i assume right yes california king
california king my wife is very
territorial if i come towards her i'm on
the edge you push me off the head yeah i
get that all the time too did the dog
sleep in the bed with you the one so i
didn't tell you the story the other dog
is a dog we acquired from my mom when
she passed away she got it as a rescue
it's this little piece of [ __ ]
we now love
it's like half jack russell half
chihuahua and that dog sleeps on the bed
with us the other one has a
crate and how many pillows do you
personally use
i assume you have
significant others that are pillow
people because i wouldn't i wouldn't
know women were so into pillows if we're
not for my wife uh-huh there's like 19
pillows on the bed i used to use two so
do you have two below your head
yes you do you don't hug one or no
between your legs oh no i as i've gotten
older i've got shoulder and neck and
stuff so i have to like so it's just two
pillows you sleep on your side if i
sometimes depends on my shoulders are
doing okay they'll literally trigger the
pain and wake me up and you guys have a
you have a fan on you when you sleep no
do you fall asleep with the tv on no i
have but not not retaining dear read
before you go to bed sometimes oh that's
pretty good that's pretty good kippy
what do you got for him
uh how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken
well you get a rotisserie chicken yeah
from the supermarket for like 8.99 or
whatever yeah yeah you do and then do
you just eat that or do it was that like
for the meal for dinner were you and
your wife sort of available like my for
my
non-carb intake sure
perfect
yeah grazing picking now do you guys
will you guys do frozen pizza at the
house yeah we have we we're
spoiled by new york you know okay yeah
all right pizza
pizza will get like california pizza
kitchen once in a while okay that's
pretty classiest of the frozen what
about encounters it's not it's the most
like chain pizza yeah but it's better
than a digiorno yeah
[Applause]
but i'm a dirt bag i'm talking to an
esteemed doctor over here if you get
pizza at the house out in california you
guys will just order from regular pizza
place
uh there's no dominoes showing up to
your house
[Music]
not regularly at all but i'm sure we've
done it yeah i'm sure we're done
with it there's a group of people but
you know we have this place called big
mamas that has a pretty decent probably
pretty good shout out to big mama huh
yeah
uh have you ever microwaved bacon oh
yeah really yes not from raw but to
reheat
routinely routinely what happens if you
get an egg that has two yolks in it will
you eat it hell yeah and celebrate it
we eat quail eggs yes
huh what kind of coffee pot do you have
at the house we have uh
we drink a lot of coffee okay uh and so
here it's a i think it's a i think it's
like a cuisinart and at home it's like a
mr coffee okay bits of
the big pot
no espresso machine or anything like
that we have the
netspresso thing okay
once in a while i hate that [ __ ] garbage
disposal at the house hell yeah oh it's
southern california that everybody has
those there okay you have a girl do you
have a i'm assuming you have how many
let's just put it this way how many
refrigerators are on the property
at our home home yeah yeah
probably got an outdoor one you probably
got a garage you got the kitchen we have
outdoor kitchen the kitchen also has a
drawer thing for two drawers for drinks
okay and then there's a mini bar there's
a bar with this refrigerator
and that's what i'm talking about that's
probably the refrigerator that's
probably the classiest if you were gonna
have a beer yeah what would you have
i i like coronas okay yeah because it
reminds me of being down a baja sure
okay
uh if you make a purchase will you get
cash back
if i'm owed it what do you mean no
[Laughter]
that's your dad talking right i know
that's what i'm saying he's always my
[ __ ] change like he's always the back
of my mind you go to like a cvs
you got 10 bucks you want to give me if
you go to a cvs you have to pull a knife
on you
you're buying batteries with a debit
card when you get 10 20 cash back oh no
no no okay yeah all right fair enough
you open your eyes under water in the
pool [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i would buy yeah ocean if i need to i do
i was a lifeguard i had to find people
under water sometimes
eyes are closed just reaching out i like
it but you have to do it swim with his
glasses on he just got stunned by
darkness i know
dr dude just called me a [ __ ] my mom's
gonna be thrilled
can you juggle doc a lit i had been able
to i'd
but i don't know if i could now do you
know karate
i took karate classes when i was a kid i
really don't but okay from uh
from a guy who was elvis presley's
bodyguard wow forget his name that's
also something somebody would lie about
no no
because this guy had a car that elvis
gave him and he used to tell us about it
and he was uh [ __ ] i remember his name
he's in the he's named in some of the
books and stuff really helps yeah yeah
yeah riley from melbourne isn't that
funny but i was like six years old oh
yeah that's what that's the age that
karate is acceptable if you're doing
karate in your mid-20s it's a tough look
did you by any chance participate in
hands across america i don't think i did
did you go to live aid or band-aid or
anything like that i i saw it but i
didn't go anywhere okay you didn't go
too yeah do you know how to use
chopsticks oh yeah is there magnets on
your fridge no no magnets no magnets
which is interesting right i've thought
about it the other day i was going to
get some i thought we don't do magnets
yes don't do that uh have you ever taken
a bath at a hotel
i'm sure oh yes yes for sure really can
you play chess
not well okay do you know anybody that's
ever worked at hooters
i'm sure i do but not often not not
somebody i'm close to okay
celebrity rehab
deona jetski no [ __ ] up pretty good
have you ever used the thigh master no
but i know suzanne summers very well
that's awesome
but i can't believe i just asked dr drew
if you ever use the thighs lovely let's
say you were you'd ask me anything it's
getting better better
why don't you get some really wild stuff
going come on i'm ready for you guys
let's know this [ __ ] in that list that
you you're afraid to ask me keep it in
the middle of the road i want you to ask
yourself how big's your dick doctor
holy [ __ ] something like that
something
years let's go is there it is there a
doctor
i don't know
eight and a half it's not that does not
sound too big
have any celebrities that you've never
met dm'd you a picture of something on
their body and said do you know what
this is
that i've never met no but that i've met
yet i'm sure i'm sure you're fielding a
lot of like
friends and colleagues
oh yeah and so and i really feel
strongly it's about doing it too because
i i i had an extraordinary clinical
experience right that that almost no one
has now across
critical care general medicine and
psychiatry yeah and addiction and
there's no one person that sees that
spectrum anymore
very specialized
and i just want to give that back if
people have questions i want to i'm
happy to go you are now my primary care
family
i got something on my leg i want you to
take a look at it right before we let
you get out and done
will you when you're eating a burger if
you eat a burger will you cut it in half
rarely rarely now when you're but i get
the you remember i get the lettuce wraps
too sure i may eat it with a knife a
fork too
classy
classy
nothing better in and out guys nothing
better so what i was gonna ask you let's
say you are at a grocery store
say you're buying a gallon of milk will
you take the first milk that's there or
will you reach back and get the milk
from behind it i will look at the dates
you'll look at the dates and you'll dig
back to find the the newest one i won't
try too hard but i will i'll
do a little date examination
anybody in your family or you ever
claim to have seen a ufo
no okay do you will you use the safe at
a hotel yes really my wife uses it all
the time i will not she uses every time
i have to struggle with it are there
magazines in your bathroom
um i used to read a lot in my bathroom
but they were like medical journals and
philosophy books okay but uh not like
sports illustrated
leafing through a southern hospitality
magazines sort of don't exist anymore
yeah they're kind of phased out you
bring your phone when you're on the
toilet yes you do 100
uh can you name any of the guys from
pawn stars
by i could i would i'd be able to
identify them by sight yeah at least the
two guys the main guy in the sun okay uh
who's got a big beard now i almost
didn't recognize him rick harrison is a
gentleman you're right yeah yes and chum
lee shout out trump chumbley yes
chumbley yes
and big horse on the old man i love it i
love those guys do you wipe front to
back
front to back front to back
i'm not a terrorist
do you pee sitting down or standing up
uh standing up but but um
yeah standing up i mean it's again my
everything's a little because of my
prostate disease sure but it's standing
up what's the undies situation what do
you do boxers brief boxer briefs boxer
briefs the gentleman john don't you guys
advertise not a tommy john guy yeah but
we're open to it
tommy i don't know who we are this week
but we're probably somebody what do you
sleep with
uh nothing or my boxer brief really
depends what we're into that night the
one with the wife and i sleeping naked
right sometimes we're all busy then when
we go to bed so i'm saying or in the
morning
and by the way it's it's sort of if
we're not it's kind of a message that
it's time sure
sure there you go have you ever owned
your own pool cue or bowling ball
uh we have a pool table no bowling ball
okay you guys are you guys shy away from
the sexual stuff i noticed you pulled
right back from yeah we're repressed
irish catholic all right
i'm talking to an expert my wife and i
have a lot of sex yes you want to talk
about it yeah that's what i'm talking
about shout out to the doc
boom you own a pocket knife
probably somewhere but not in recent
time is there a painting of you and the
family anywhere in the house there's a
no there's a kind of a picture painting
of our kids when they were little okay
though have you ever gone to watch the
implosion of a building
i've watched it plenty online but never
gone to see one okay i've sought it out
online the dunes hotel going down was my
favorite really that's [ __ ] weird
that's right that has real building
seven bodies
my mom used to perform this so i never
finished the whole story about her yeah
so she was an opera singer herself right
when she was absconded with by the old
man the 60 year old man
uh and she was 18 20 yeah do you know
who that star was yeah i could never
remember his name i just can't so it
wasn't like errol flynn or anything like
that no but he was one of the most
prolific western stars of the history
and um
and she lived apparently by the la brea
tar pits you know sort of in that area
and she would always regale us with
stories about her because she ended up
in films and film noir and she ended up
singing for big bands and so she's
opened the dunes hotel that's what she
so that dunes are fascinates me i guess
when there was that makes sense before
the tower when there was a big genie on
the roof do you know those pictures sure
genie on the roof no you don't genie on
the roof of the dunes
stories about her friends like carolyn
jones and barbara eden and she would
hung with ang bancroft a lot this
because these were her friends sure and
her stepsons when i talked to him he
goes yeah my dad drank a lot and that's
probably why she left and he was a
little he's not a great guy
and uh but they would have these couple
over every sunday night they had a party
every sunday night the man he told me
his name i didn't stay with me it was
some sort of well-known character movie
actor okay and he goes the mom the the
woman of this couple i don't know you
may you may have heard of her yeah you
ever see granny in the beverly
hillbillies i'm like what what jesus i
would say irene
she's somebody there's something she
there's she has another wild story that
then she died on stage playing pippen
right here on broadway oh really yeah
and uh
any event i was like you should never
mention that about old childhood i
watched the beverly hillbillies and she
never said oh yeah i knew her
party partied with that chick yeah right
irene ryan right ryan yes um you guys
ever go to sandals you ever go down to
sandals no but uh i was in one of our
cruises we end up at a sandals adjacent
beach
okay yeah what about hedonism you ever
go down there no get freaky but uh there
was a guy
back on love line we used to make fun of
some of the people that with some of the
videos that were online with that the
the ripping and the tears they're
ripping and tearing right now
yeah we used to make so much fun of that
guy oh
i've been dropping ripping in the
tearing on here for like two minutes on
the tear and the wild women the wild
women the ripping of the terror the
ripping of the territory never spend any
time at the playboy mansion yes i'll
tell you that whoa and we um
we actually tracked that dude down oh
[ __ ] he was like like a
social studies teacher in arizona
it was like he was really like really
you got to see the video it's a wild
it's just a guy getting interviewed at
hedonism
and he has others who found other words
so anyway uh would you ask me do i have
a playboy
so uh the the release the release party
or the whatever it was for love line
back in the day i was there
uh i did uh politically incorrect i used
to do that show all the time and he
would occasionally do that at the
breadboard match i did that
and then i went with a friend of mine
over there to have lunch with a guy that
ran the playboy tv lunch yeah they serve
lunch in there what did you have
i don't remember i don't remember but
but i was i found it so just had the
bunny burger
lettuce wrap but it it really weirded me
out at that point i was like oh my god
you guys are all 75 years old you're
getting like you're 28. it's weird yeah
it was like a restaurant or like they're
just serving lunch like lunch in the
living room dining room yeah
it was very very weird for the condom in
your cobb set i mean it was like
yeah the first time i was there was the
love line launch party and i was like
hey it's cool the grotto's here oh you
know the zoo and everything and i
remember i became friends with uh oh
crap i'm blanking on his son's name
um
tommy hefner
yeah i can't remember his name right now
but he was a little kid sitting in the
window i remember when we had that
launch party and he's good he's a good
guy like his son good good guy cooper
cooper thank you very much and sorry
growing up in the playboy man
cooper's a very good guy
smart dude have you ever gone ghost
hunting
my wife has she's big into it she's way
into sidekicks and ghosts and all these
ghosts
i don't know what she's doing over there
i listen i love my wife and whatever
she's into
who am i to say you know what i mean i i
have humility i have humility in all
things i tried definitely all things
have you ever seen the harlem
globetrotters play not in person
you know it's back to the my mom and the
psychic thing so my my wife used to have
uh a psychic podcast called her friends
psychics okay and uh she had my mom on
for one and it was actually like uh
while she was alive or yeah yeah and she
came in
and it was uh kind of a famous psychic
i'm not remember who it was right now
but but uh chris angel
he's a mind freak he's not a psychic
everybody knows this this is also carrot
chris is a friend character really
chris you're boys with angel yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] he's a really good guy really
good guy that's a big fan of the show
uh hey chris
i don't think he's watching
but uh could be in the room
he could pull that off
but so yeah
my watch is gone that was the funniest
thing you've ever said
not a high
bar
all right now he's [ __ ] on both of
us you set me up
you see they call me a [ __ ]
so he my mom calls in he doesn't know
it's my mom he doesn't know who's
calling in and he goes okay well let me
see and he goes first thing she goes oh
your husband's here and she goes oh mort
my dad and he goes uh
no that's not who it is he says he's
your first husband and she goes
i i know what you're talking about
[Music]
take it to the grave yeah shout out to
your mom yeah i consistently and then my
the guy got pissed he was like no no the
guy insists he's right
yeah and she goes i don't you you're
you're mistaken your mom turns into
paulie walnuts you've been talking to
holy [ __ ]
i think i'm pretty do most people like
answering these questions these are
great oh yeah yeah yeah give me some
hard balls come on that's the thing
they're not it's all you know all just
general stuff yeah yeah that's what
makes it clever it would be a hardball
question i don't know i'm used to
hardback i used to i don't know i'm yeah
we sneak into the news people trying to
find out how you're doing people trying
to humiliate no no no no no no not at
all you crazy we asked you about your
piece i don't know
i don't know what else you want to
reveal all right you want to argue
garbage hardball it's a classic okay
growing up did you drink milk with
dinner
uh i
probably maybe early on but not later
did you with your kids drink i had one
kid that really liked milk and my wife
likes milk and we'll drink it with stuff
but uh
probably as a kid i drink soda
breathe yeah
yeah what's your go-to soda if you
when's the last time you had soda
yesterday diet really diet yeah
had a little wave going down because it
was the coolest guy the biggest head on
the root bear so we like that yeah
um obviously you don't need any fast
food [ __ ] my shoe the soles coming off
my shoe that's how much i just realized
this that's right now yes look at this
[ __ ] look watch
i
he's got a nice pair of chelsea boots on
so i don't know what's happening
now will you get that fixed or throw
them out and get a new pair
it depends what you're getting that's
depends how much it costs
going to happen is i know a really good
competitive i'm going to put some super
glue on it if that doesn't work i might
get rid of them your doctor joined your
superglue in your shoes yes
what do you think
it's right it's again this is another
one where it's like right down the
middle of yours right
but the boutique it's this it's that
trying to think what what more good
example of my wife's white trash stuff i
mean
you know fights at weddings lots of that
kind of stuff
throwing down at her family's weddings
for sure oh yeah really where's her
family based out of now it's orange
everyone's pretty much gone everyone's
gone but it was orange county los
angeles fights at weddings you got to
step in
no because uh one of her one of her
cousin-in-laws
there was a fighter there was a fight at
our listen to this our uh dr drew you're
digging a hole for yourself
i want a classy esteem gentleman
the um our what do you call it when a
wedding uh party you know the wedding uh
rehearsal dinner rehearsal no no the
reception
shower wedding shower oh i put on a big
wedding shower for a bridal shower
bridal shower exactly and uh we all
we're all there we're outdoors and all
of a sudden we see the walls practically
cave in from this bedroom we're like
what is going on
turned out they took all the women's
purses and dress and you know sweaters
and things that put them in this one
bedroom some dude pretended to be a
caterer and was in there rifling through
everything nice and the guy whose
mother's house it was went in there and
found him called the cop in and they
beat the [ __ ]
yeah
and hog tied him with wire hangers there
you go that's a little wild he had he
had a bunch of [ __ ] on him he was
robbing the hell out of everybody there
and we threw him in the ocean no no
cops came i remember i'll never forget
that charlie was the guy was the cop and
he goes i had to use
what did he call it like necessary force
he was like just enough force to control
the situation it was just the necessary
kind of tied up with a sweeper uh where
do you get your hair cut uh it's a my
wife was a cosmetologist white trash
okay uh she didn't graduate
during during during
high school she got her cosmetology
thing because she got depressed and left
high school
uh and she makes it like a like a
hobby out of finding
places and she tells me where to go so
there's one place called bravo in
pasadena okay how much does it cost um
she used to give me a really ridiculous
deal and i told her to please stop doing
that i think it's about seventy dollars
fifty to seventy in there okay and then
what do you tip on that
all in all
you do massages no i have i don't really
dig it that much okay um
all right
i mean i think we i'm exhausting you
guys this is like i feel like uh sort of
uh sort of uh
exhibit exactly yeah well it's tough to
make a if i'm being honest here i mean
you kind of write down
okay um
by any chance
in a non-celebrity capacity
were you ever a contestant on the wheel
of fortune but you know that to be true
so
so this case is close yeah
so a friend of mine is first year
medical school and a friend of mine went
on there won a car and i was like [ __ ] i
need a car
if he can do it i can do it and so i you
went on wheel of fortune to win a car
so it was the two weeks between
medical school and residency i had two
weeks nothing to do so i went down to
merv griffin studios wait in line we're
talking what 81 82 uh 84. this is prime
time wheel of fortune yeah yeah yeah and
got on and just got my ass handed to me
by the wheel
and and it was
and i saw i like to buy a number how do
you do it and the woman next to me just
cleaned up just cleaned up
you you forget that the wheel can go
against you you're like
things rigged
that's it doc you're trash i'm telling
you right now he's blaming the wheel and
that was always a fact that goddamn
vanna white was paying off always afraid
that that footage would show up one day
really and i was it i was on ellen about
three or four years ago okay and she
goes hey we have a surprise and i was
like oh no
and it should be removed from the setup
there it was it was it was as pathetic
as i thought it was he's got a big throw
bro oh it's just the full 1980s
it was
horrible
and uh you're screaming about a setup
and ellen asked a great question she
goes did you learn anything from this
and uh and i said yes face your fears
this was the thing i feared more than
almost anything else and it wasn't that
bad it was exactly what i thought it was
it's awesome it's awful but i made it
through i love how everybody showed this
is worried about like tweets coming out
or old dms he's like i hope they don't
get me [ __ ] hitting bankruptcy
[Laughter]
i got three whammies i'm screwed just
such an [ __ ] i was an [ __ ] when i
was a kid
awesome though ladies and gentlemen the
legendary dr drew this was fun i can do
this all night thank you so much welcome
back whenever you're in new york anytime
you're in town we'd love to have you is
there anything you want the folks out
there no are there nasty questions in
here so that we have a car we have a car
that's our card game so we uh it's out
of stock at the moment
state quarters uh you ever collect them
they were big they they hit in the
like that but no it was like collect
them all a lot of people thought that
thank you weird i was waking i woke up
this morning i had a dream about
somebody else's house i was going to and
they had a snake and i thought boy that
doesn't get more white trash than that
yeah snakes snakes are very trapped i
thought and i thought
have you ever traveled across state
landed by fireworks well yes as a kid
[ __ ] yes that's for hillbilly that's
hillbilly you kids make sure you send
them off in your hands
and don't forget to call dr drew no
scarface poaching lottery tickets i have
yeah but not like you know not yet
you're doing scratchers not for real
trophies on home no not anymore
uh put aftermarket products on your car
when i was a spoiler
when i was a kid it used to be a big
thing to put you know stereos in your
hair yeah stereos it was huge got neon
lights on the dented porsche
dr drew i love these cards
gone to a wax museum at a family
vacation hell yeah you just made the
promo reel for the next commercial
you're now a celebrity endorser
do i have to go
you have to you don't have to don't get
lucky what do you mean you keep coming
up with the same ones you can give me a
physical
toilet seat
but but those those uh
those squirting ones are pretty good
hot pockets three for six five days
here's one then we'll let you get out of
here any family members hitting you up
for cash
not well yes
sure
but it's not really the family members
that that are the shocker it's when
friends do it you know okay
do you have a go-to are you like ah or
because we thought of that it's it's
either like you have to
it's very hard to either have to say yes
to everybody or know to everybody a
little bit i hand it off to my wife she
does all the hard work she makes the
determination of whether they get it or
not those eastern europeans she does the
hard work she's better at saying no if
it's appropriate there you go good holy
[ __ ] dr drew ladies and gentlemen i love
you buddy thank you sir thank you so
much.com for all the pods
tv for the streaming show we do it three
o'clock tuesday wednesday and thursdays
uh your mom's house we need more love
over there we need you guys at dr drew
after dark we need your fans because uh
for whatever reason they've headed over
to two bears one cave so those two guys
are in here so head on back to after
dark we're we're we'll come we'll have
you guys on we love that brother we'd
love that email if you know you're tom
we're gonna be in l.a next week we don't
know what we're doing in austin boston
your mom's house has a whole
world
operation tommy's got a whole compound
down he does we'll have to come down and
do it and line up some other pods yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right guys thank you
thank you sir thank you so much gang we
love you we'll see you next week peace